my entrepreneur friend Kevin David went
from working an accounting job that he
hated to in less than 18 months becoming
a millionaire using Facebook Ads Shopify
and Amazon FBA he now teaches people how
they can do the same in this video
Kevin's gonna teach us how to sell on
Amazon FBA for beginners in an easy
step-by-step tutorial I hope you enjoy
and there's a special link below to get
more free training from Kevin alright
thanks so much for that intro evan i'll
further ado let's jump into my computer
I'm gonna teach you two step-by-step
strategies that I've taught over 10,000
of my students how to create a
profitable Amazon business in just three
steps let's go so today we're gonna be
talking about the three-step blueprint
that I've taught over ten thousand of my
students writing hundreds of thousands
of people on YouTube and social media
from around the world the three-step
system that we use to create a
profitable business I'm using Amazon FBA
right Amazon FBA is fulfillment by
Amazon so a lot of people don't realize
that over 50% of things sold on Amazon
are actually sold by people like you and
me right it's not actually sold by
Amazon and so how do you actually choose
which product to actually sell that's
the hard part right but that's what
we're gonna be talking about in step
number one step number one is choosing
the right product doing product research
and that letting Amazon actually do all
the hard work for us right fulfillment
by Amazon means they package your
product they ship it out they handle all
the customer service they accept payment
and then they basically just cut you a
check for your earnings twice a month
every single month so it's a really
really incredible business model because
you can leverage all of Amazon's
millions of actual loyal customers and
not have to go out and get all the
customers for yourself right so what
we're gonna talk about in step one is
product research how to find profitable
products so what we're looking at right
here is the the software that I
currently use to actually sort through
all of the multiple millions of
different products on Amazon FBA when it
comes to actually choosing a product
there's a few things that are in very
very important so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna cut down the category since
we don't want to be looking for products
in appliances apps and games right we
don't we're not gonna sell cameras
alongside Canon but we can sell you know
little trinkets in home and
kitchen or you know baby or health and
household so what we've done is we've
cut down the categories to kind of be
the ones that I've proven to be most
profitable you know the one that we
probably made the most in we've made you
know multiple millions of dollars in the
home and kitchen section alone so what
we're gonna be looking at is we don't
want to sell anything less than 14
dollars because since Amazon does all
the fulfillment for us they obviously
take a fee to do all of that hard work
anything below 14 dollars is really
difficult to make a 50% profit margin or
more so we're gonna cap it at the
minimum we want to look at products that
are fourteen dollars or more now what we
want to do is make sure that we actually
choose a monthly revenue range because
we don't want to see products that
aren't selling anything but we also
don't want to see products that are
selling and you know a million dollars a
month because that brings with it a lot
of competition and negativity and just
nasty stuff that you don't want to deal
with so what I've kind of proven to be
kind of the sweet spot range it's kind
of between at $9,000 a month and 19,000
dollars a month and then the most
important thing is we don't want to
actually try to go compete with other
sellers they have thousands or tens of
thousands of reviews you're never gonna
be able to compete with that and so what
we want to do is come in here and make
sure that we're only looking at products
that have a maximum of you know let's
say 75 76 reviews so now what we're
gonna do is we're going to go to show
keywords and now viral launch is going
to show us products that meet all of the
criteria that we actually set we can see
that there's back-handspring trainer
there's hand clap right Jeep lift kit is
pen walk keg Alois couch recliner golf
pull carts all different types of
products right people don't realize that
there's literally millions of products
on Amazon there's golf pull carts
there's an you know a transit levels
like I don't even know what that is
let's open up a few of these like golf
pull carts might be interesting let's do
back handspring trainer that sounds a
little bit ridiculous but let's check it
out and let's look onto the next set
goal disposable flatware laser training
gun let's try this out
sisqó phone a mono microwave so let's
take a look at these three products
right and I have no idea if these are
gonna actually be good or not but you
know what you can see right here is
laser training gun has nine point six
thousand of revenue per month right so
it's selling close to ten thousand
dollars worth in revenue per month with
you know a very healthy profit margin
and remember these are estimates what I
like to rely on more is actually the
Chrome extension once we get inside here
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
run the market intelligence Chrome
extension which is just another version
of the viral launch tool that allows us
to look through all these different
products and so what we're gonna do is
we're going to open this up a little bit
make it a little bit bigger so we can
see everything and this is gonna show us
all of the different monthly revenues
reviews and things like that so if we
sort by review quantity right what we
can see is you know some of these have
very low reviews with pretty solid
revenues like this one has 27 reviews
with twelve thousand four hundred and
ninety eight dollars per month revenue
so let's actually open up this one right
here so this particular laser hit dry
fire training kit it looks like they're
selling you know some targets
it's a charger something to like record
your phone or something like that and
then the actual laser itself so they're
selling kind of a kit here and so you
can see that this product is literally
selling thirteen thousand dollars a
month every single month and it's like
the most random product on earth that
you'd never even think about so this is
definitely a product that I would
consider selling so you can see you know
seventeen thousand dollars here with
only sixty two reviews which is again
very very possible for us to actually
come in and overtake that product get
some reviews you know make better
pictures create a better product listing
we can see this product listing is very
weak you know this particular I don't
even know what I'm exactly I'm getting
here but it's just an interesting
product cuz people are you know
basically creating like a shooting range
without an actual gun so it's definitely
an interesting idea and so it's
definitely something that I would come
back to and save for later so let's look
at the next thing we can see that this
is a backhand spring trainer so if we
run market intelligence here what we can
see is the actual numbers for the
back-handspring Tran so he makes a
little bit bigger what we can see is
some pretty good-looking monthly
revenues right some crazy stuff eighty
one thousand dollars per month so if we
actually sort by review quantity here
what we're gonna see is some really
interesting stuffs fourteen thousand
eight hundred and seventy nine dollars
it kind of meets the criteria between
our nine and nineteen thousand anything
over kind of twenty K H per month is
gonna bring a lot of competitors in my
experience and so I like to kind of you
know use the tortoise and the hare
analogy where I'm the hair or excuse me
I'm the tortoise and I create you know a
lot of products that don't bring a
million competitors but if you add you
know one two three like up to ten
products that are each doing fifteen
thousand or so dollars per month right
ten products which you can easily do
within a year is a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars you know in passive
income every single month from your
Amazon business which is very possible
and I have you know hundreds of students
who've done the exact same thing so if
we look at a couple of these like
fourteen thousand here are almost
fifteen thousand one following eighteen
or views we can see that this is a
junior training bar for kids right so
it's like a it's like a ballerina bar
gymnastics bar I guess 18 reviews two
hundred 39.99 right so it's an
interesting product for sure let's look
at another one eighteen thousand so this
is a folding gymnastics cheese wedge
incline mat right so this is definitely
an interesting product again it's pretty
expensive which is all which is
interesting because it being expensive
kind of deters a lot of other actual
Amazon sellers from potentially
competing with you so this is definitely
a product that I would also look at and
we'll take a look at this final one
which is Golf Cart our golf pull carts
here and if we make this a little bit
bigger we can see that there's also some
really strong looking monthly revenue
here if we sort by reviews we can see
that you know with one review this
product has thirteen thousand dollars in
monthly revenue which is you know very
very strong so what it looks like this
product actually does is just you know
carries an actual set of golf clubs
right so it's not a particularly
complicated product or anything like
that what we can see is you know there's
some very very strong numbers with again
very low reviews forty seven thousand
dollars a month probably a little bit
too much than what we're interested in
but definitely
very strong $11,000 a month with only 17
reviews definitely something that we
would check out so all three products
that we found in a very short period of
time just by using basic filters to sort
through all the millions of products on
Amazon we were able to find three
potential products that we would
actually go out find a supplier for and
ship over from the u.s. from China to
the USA right directly to an Amazon FBA
warehouse and in this video we're not
going to talk about actually how to find
suppliers but it's actually very easy to
do so what I recommend is checking out
my youtube just searching Kevin David
suppliers or manufacturers and I've done
a lot of videos on that but alibaba.com
is the largest manufacturer website in
the world you can literally find
anything like the people on Alibaba are
the ones making iPhones they're the ones
making everything so all you have to do
is just use Alibaba comm to search and
you can find a manufacturer to make you
literally anything it's actually much
easier than people think people just get
overwhelmed and they don't realize you
know actually how doable this is and we
have hundreds of students doing it you
know in my programs every single day
making tens hundreds or even multiple
hundreds of thousands of dollars a month
with their amazon businesses from
scratch so part one guys is product
research how to find a profitable
product part two is we want to actually
make sure that those products have the
correct keywords right because what
happens sometimes is you'll get a
product that looks good on the surface
but there's just not enough keywords
there's not enough search volume there's
not enough different ways to say to call
a product like for example there was a
product that got kind of popular about a
year ago called an angle eyes drooler
and angle eyes rulers were super popular
on Amazon you know a lot of people
started to kind of create private label
brands with them
but the only way you can really refer to
an angle eyes drooler is an angle eyes
ruler so there's only there's only one
keyword there was not that much search
volume and so it got very congested and
and really wasn't a very profitable
niche to be in for people after they
kind of jumped in another example would
be like a gift like a coffee mug for for
a mom you can call that gift for mom
that could be a gift for Grandma for
some people gift for aunt it could be
you know all these different terms
coffee mugs funny coffee mug you know
all these different terms took
all the same products because people
don't just literally type in the exact
name of a product into the Amazon search
bar they'll type in like gift for Mom or
they'll type it in like golf or things
like that and they'll look for all these
different products and then they'll buy
things and so you know if you take some
of those some of those examples that we
that we just looked at like we can type
in like laser here and what we're using
right here is a tool called zon keywords
this is like the strongest tool when it
comes to actually doing keyword research
it'll give you a smart score that shows
you how much search volume relative to
the number of sellers obviously the
higher the score the more search volume
and the less sellers are because you
want people to be searching a lot but
not many people selling it it also shows
you you know the seasonality indicator
my kind of rule of thumb for my students
is you want this to be above 50 if it's
above 50 that means that there's enough
and there's strong enough kind of search
volume year-round because what you don't
want to have is a product that people
only buy once a year you know like
Christmas lights or something like that
and so you get a bunch of sales and kind
of going into December but no sales the
rest of the year so if we type in laser
gun you know we can see a lot of results
here we can see a word cloud and we can
see that people actually type in a lot
of different search terms did they end
up buying because what what song
keywords does that a lot of other tools
don't do is they show you buyer intent
keywords with real data pulled directly
from Amazon right a lot of the other
tools make all these estimations and
just use Google Keyword planner I mean
it's not actually entirely relevant to
the product itself but with zon keywords
what's on keywords does is it actually
shows buyer and tank keywords so what we
can see here as we see like laser tag
toy guns gif for 10 year-old boys right
all these different terms that could
potentially actually you know have
somebody who wants to buy it like a
laser gun set which is the first part
that we looked at and so if we type in
back-handspring you know what we can see
here is there's a number of different
ways to actually do this right so we can
see gymnastic equipments for girls
gymnastic equipment for kids gymnastics
rollers we can see back handspring
trainer gymnastics springboard back
handspring trainers gymnastics barrel
smarter spot or gymnastic equipment for
home for kids a lot of different ways to
say this right relatively low search
volume but these are more expensive
products so you don't need as many
searches you don't need as much volume
right so that's kind of the thought
process that I go through
when I actually go to create these to do
my keyword research so if we do golf
pull carts the last product that we
looked at and we can take a look at some
of the keyword data for this particular
product we can see that's a little bit
more seasonal right people obviously
golf you know at different portions of
the year but relatively strong and we
can see a lot of different terms here
like golf push cart four wheels three
wheels bag umbrellas caddy
you know golf walking carts electric
golf walking carts lots of different
ways to kind of stay the same thing we
see thousands of monthly searches bagboy
golf ball [ __ ] golf caddy golf cart
wheels golf pull carts pull car at kids
golf cart golf golf push carts right
lots of different ways to say the same
thing so good that's kind of step two
part one is doing product research part
two is validating the products that you
find to make sure that there's enough
keywords and enough different kind of
ways to search for that product that you
can eventually rank for those different
keywords and things like that and then
part three is actually understanding
Amazon's algorithm how Amazon actually
ranks products and how Amazon will you
know push products up into the first
page because what people don't realize
is that Amazon has a first page right
all these different products that we see
right here and then they have page two
and the rest of the pages the thing is
with Amazon like anything else it's like
Google right how often do you actually
scroll to page two on Google how often
do you scroll to page two on Amazon
because for me it's almost never right
and that's the same thing with most
people so if you're not on page one for
the search results for your product
right if you're selling a garlic press
if you're not on page one you're
basically on no page because know almost
nobody Scrolls to page two right so you
have to be on page one and to be on page
one for your search results you have to
understand how to actually rank your
product to page one right so how do you
do that the only way to actually rank
your product to page one is by using a
launch service right what they do is
they basically essentially you know tell
Amazon's algorithm which is called the
aa9 algorithm
it tells Amazon's algorithm that your
product should be on page one because
how Amazon ranks all of their different
products are
you know multiple millions of products
they use a tool called B SR which stands
for best seller rank and so what this
means is if your product essentially
gets more sales and has more sales
velocity than a product that's already
on page one so let's say that this
product right here is selling ten units
per day if you come in with your new
garlic press and you start selling
eleven units per day and you sustain
that 11 units per day over a seven day
window what's gonna happen is Amazon's a
nine other algorithm is gonna say okay
this product is selling more we need to
move it in front of this product that's
currently on page one and so we use a
tool called page one if I and what page
one if I basically does is it tells
Amazon to a nine algorithm that your
product is actually selling more and so
they go out there and they find people
to actually buy your product eleven of
your products per day at a discounted
rate they land page one if I will find
you eleven buyers per day for seven
straight days until your product gets to
page one and once your product is on
page one you're gonna get exposed to
thousands of eyes of eyeballs of people
who actually want to buy garlic presses
and then you're gonna maintain that
ranking that you actually get to page
one organically and that's the beauty of
Amazon when you don't have to pay for
traffic there's no paid traffic it's all
organic sales and that's when you really
start to create a real sustainable
profitable organic business with Amazon
FBA so to recap guys step number one is
product research finding a profitable
product with low amount of reviews a
reasonable amount of revenue nine to
nineteen thousand dollars in revenue per
month anything above that brings too
many people too much competition once
you find a product right step two is
validating that product with keyword
research making sure that there's enough
monthly searches that there's multiple
ways that people could type in to find
your product and then step three is
understanding how to actually rank your
products once you launch it to page one
so that you get all the organic millions
of customers for free that Amazon
already has browsing the platform we
have one more thing Evans gonna mention
in just a few seconds but I hope you
enjoyed that quick look into how to
start a profitable business on Amazon
back to you Evan Kevin is having a free
webinar training to take you deeper and
show you step by step how you can make
more money if you're interested in
checking it out the link is in the
description below and if you want to see
Kevin's Shopify tutorial for beginners
check out the video there right next to
me I think you'll enjoy it
and continue to believe and I'll see you
there how you can get started
Shopify drop shipping with literally and
no money to get started and we're gonna
reveal the secret tool that I've taught
over 10,000 of my students